Remember when one is computing the closure, you look for the red dot
right in front of a nonterminal light key.
Oh! We found one, this is super convenient.
When you go back to the grammar and look for every rule that starts with "E"
and you put a red dot right at the beginning of it,
so we're expecting "E" goes to dot this, "E" goes to dot that, and "E" goes to dot end.
And you put from the current state, state 2.
So here, "E" goes to end becomes "E" goes to dot end from 2, that looks really good.
Here's "E" times "E". Here's dot "E" times "E" from 2. That looks really good.
Dot "E" times "E" from 0, this is not correct, so put in chart state 2,
because it has forgotten about the previous 2 characters we've seen,
and then over here, "E" goes to dot divided by "E".
This looks good. The other 3 were distractors.